to in uh to have stefan here
with us i cannot see stefan video maybe
stefan can you turn on your audio so
that i can
see you sorry can i turn on what yeah
okay
all right i can see you now okay um
so yes so stefan stephen is from uh
department of mathematical mathematics
and statistics
at lancaster university england and
uh he works on a lot of different topics
and non-parametric statistics but
i know mostly him from his work on on
multi-arm bandits
i also have the pleasure of co-authoring
a paperwork with him on delayed feedback
which was a lot of fun and so today he's
going to talk about multitask optimal
experiment design take it away
thank you so this is joint work with
maya
fazel from university of washington i
should say
this is all preliminary work so we don't
have anything on archive yet
or published but i think the framework i
discussed is quite interesting is a
setting
and i'll point out a few which i find
surprising
results so let's get to the setting
if i know how to change slides okay so
um
generally i'm dealing here with a high
dimensional hilbert space h
finite dimensional but high dimensional
just to have enough degrees of freedom
to put multitask
multitask setting in so essentially i'm
dealing with multiple
settings in which i try to infer a
parameter theta high
and i play multiple rounds and a high
dimensional hilbert space is pretty good
to model the setting generally
i have some parameter thetanol in this
high-dimensional space which is unknown
which i essentially try to infer from
data
i have a simple observation model i
might sample a point h
a and h um and get an observation which
corresponds to the usual inner product
between a
and c tan hull so the mean of the
distribution and some noise term
which for simplicity i'll assume here is
a standard normal random variable
but anything that is essentially zero
mean and has reasonably nice properties
would do so pretty much standard least
square setting
if you like nothing particularly fancy
here
now i'm interested in turning this into
a multi-task setting
so i'm interested in having multiple
airports
which i will enumerate with i so i'm
running from i
equal 1 2 3 and so on in each epoch
i get a set of actions or design points
from which i can sample
which i will generally note is ai
all of these design points are obviously
living in the hilbert space
and these design points change from
airport to airport
in each apple i can have multiple rounds
in which i'm allowed
to sample from these design points
but between airports my design points
change
goal is generally to estimate the
function
which corresponds to the mean so i'm
interested in estimating
f of a versus function f is simply
c corresponding to the inner product
between a and theta null
in our heatable space um so there's now
two variations of the problems that
make sense is i'm only interested in
estimating
my function at my design points ai or
i'm interested in estimating the
function over the whole
span of ai which i will denote in the
following this ui
so either i'm interested in getting a
good estimate for the whole subspace
or i'm only interested in the design
points
so this is obviously quite closely
related pretty much the same as
trying to estimate the projection of c
tunnel
onto the subspace ui
i will call this projection that the
projection operator
generally here is pi so these are signal
projections
onto the subspace ui and the parameter
that corresponds to my design point set
in apple i will be denoted with theta i
so this is simply the original
projection of my big
theta null onto my potentially small
subspace which corresponds to my current
epoch
um then obviously um
we have here that's the inner product
between a and theta null if
a is some design point in epoch i
is the same as inner product between a
and the orthogonal projection of c
tunnel onto ui
which is the same as the inner product
between a and theta i
so that's the quantity i care about in
apple high
so i have some figures here
unfortunately not very nicely done with
ticks
so this is all ipad drawing i hope it
still
explains a point so we have our high
dimensional hilbert space
here i depict three dimensions we have
somewhere an unknown parameter
theta null then as the game proceeds
i'll get a set of design points ai
and the corresponding subspace say for
simplicity
my first subspace is u1 so for
one-dimensional space
in which i have certain design points
from which i can sample
say in epoch 2 i get the z
i get design points which will
essentially
span the space u2 so the green area here
two-dimensional subspace
corresponds to my space which i care
about
in epoch 2. and i have zero solution
projections so this is not really ozone
but it's meant to be an orthogonal
projection
of theta null on to u1 which corresponds
to
parameter theta 1 which is the parameter
i deal with this in apparent
sending epoch 2 fc of solvent projection
of c tunnel onto that subspace
corresponding to theta 2. so the idea is
now multi-task setting
makes a multi-task setting makes only
sense if there's some information
shared between the different tasks if
there's some information you can use
from previous tasks to inform
your decisions and new tasks here
essentially the information can
potentially be passed between the tasks
if the subspace u1
is in some way close to the subspace u2
so if you think of for instance two two
dimensional subspaces
or say two one dimensional subspaces and
if you have a small angle between these
subspaces
then if you sampled a lot of points in
this subspace in ebook one
xenible hopes that this information will
help you in the new epoch
simply because both shares the same
parameter theta now
so there should be some information
passing between the epochs
in particular if the subspaces are in
some way closely aligned
so if you have if you want a small angle
between the subspaces or some other form
of distance
which is small between the subspaces
so key quantity obviously in the setting
is
some measure of distance between
subspaces it does all sorts of measures
to measure distances between subspaces a
quite common way
is to compare the orthogonal projections
treat these as operators
or matrices whatever you like and
compare
the difference in these orthogonal
projections so p
one here will be my orthogonal
projection on to
u one p two is the orthogonal projection
onto
the subspace corresponding to epoch2
and then i can look at the difference
between these organs orthogonal
projections
and measures a difference in various
norms
say the operator norm or the trace norm
or the gilbert schmidt norm slash
frobenius norm which all correspond to
different geometric properties
of c subspaces and measure differences
in
different forms so in this talk i'll
pretty much just focus on the operator
norm for simplicity
this essentially is saying that you fix
a point in subspace u1 in the unit ball
in u1
and measures the distance from x to the
projection of x onto u2
you take the maximum of that expression
with the corresponding expression
for having a point in u2 and that is
giving you the operator norm
between p1 minus p2 which corresponds to
some kind of
similarity measure between the
corresponding subspaces
and the corresponding apples
sensor setting
[Music]
so in the settings there's obviously
various interesting questions that you
can ask actually
i find the setting quite complex and i
find it more challenging to figure out
which is the right question to ask
so a lack of questions doesn't seem to
be a problem in this context
so i guess the most natural question is
how much can an estimator for theta two
profit from samples in u1 independence
of the distance between the subspaces so
generally i will use here
capital theta u1 u2 to describe the
distance between the subspaces so here's
the distance in
operator norm between your organ
projections
you might also ask the related question
of can i design somehow my experiments
in subspace u1 and u2
in a way that i profit maximally
when estimating parameters theta two um
i think in an online setting it also
makes a lot of sense
that you would have a greedy algorithm
which for instance in app of one
optimizes the estimate of theta one
without caring about future apost
the question you can ask then is how can
a
method in apple 2 profit from these
samples which are not necessarily
designed
to support your estimation in the second
airport
finally you can obviously go beyond two
airports have a whole sequence
of airports the whole sequence of design
points and corresponding subspaces
potentially with a whole sequence of
distances between these subspaces
and you can ask what is my performance
in epoch and if i have a sequence of
distances between subspaces given and i
guess
corresponding numbers of samples in z
subspaces so there's a variety of
questions that you can ask
i'll focus here on the simplest possible
question that is question one and two
i will measure the difference between
the settings using the operator norm
and i have two settings sorry two
airports one and two with corresponding
subspaces u1 and u2
and i'm interested in estimating theta
2.
my hilbert space for some part will for
simplicity simply be the span of u1 u2
so not that large dimensional set high
dimensional
but see propositions are state work for
the more general case
where you have a high dimensional
hilbert space um
was there a question or is that like
quick question uh
so i guess based on what you just said
about that the hebrew space is the span
of
both of these um operators or whatnot
uh i assume that u1 and you two are
given in advance
yes yes because they could be the
variation of the problem that you know
you won you don't know you two yet
and then i agree i mean absolutely
further variations for the list
absolutely agree you might have some
uh yeah you don't know what happens in
the future which tasks
pop up in the future you might already
want to design
put certain points certainly sign points
to make it easier for future
apples yes absolutely you can play with
that
okay
good yeah oh just
okay um so let's start with a simple
estimator obviously i need to have some
estimation procedure
to discuss this whole idea of profiting
from all samples in new apos
so let's start with something very basic
just
estimate uh theta null using all data
from all the
subspaces from all the airports and
project it onto the subspace
in which you're currently at simplest
possible estimator i would say
sea tunnel can be for instance sea
tunnel head can for instance be the
ordinarily squares or maximum likelihood
estimator
that's the one i will use here of theta
null and then you project
this estimator using the orthogonal
projection to get an estimate
of your parameter theta2
there's a few properties standard stats
properties which are directly
useful um this is invariance property or
for principle of maximum likelihood
estimation which is saying
that if you apply a function to maximum
likelihood estimators and the result
is the maximum likelihood estimator of
that parameters that you care about
in this context what this is saying is
that theta hat 2 is the maximum
likelihood estimator of theta 2.
then you have all these asymptotic
efficiency statements for maximum
likelihood estimators
in this context is is saying that theta
had two approaches in minimum variance
unbiased estimator of theta to
s and goes to infinity i should mention
here this is when you keep the apos
fixed and let n go to infinity
um okay so i had like i was thinking it
might be interesting to
make this a bit more interactive i don't
know if the chat is open now
yeah just a quick question can i ask
okay can i ask this question is that
your question because i want
people if possible just okay all right
type in abcd what's your guess is about
these estimators
comparing the estimate i just discussed
with the ordinarily squares estimators
that only use the samples from apple2
so if you like to vote in the chat i
would be very happy to
get your intuition and yeah please the
question
was there a question
i was just going to ask to clarify
whether the projector operator the p1 p2
are known to the algorithm yes so the
subspaces and design points are known so
all these things are known
only unknown is a parameter now okay
so i don't know i can't see the chat um
if anyone actually typed anything
voted or not yeah everyone can
conjecture i think we need a little more
time to read the questions okay so that
quickly explains it for different the
question is
the naive estimator could be biased or
unbiased that's deciding between a b
and c d you would imagine that the
variance of the naive estimator
improves compared to the estimator which
uses only samples from epoch2
i guess it also might be quite natural
to assume such
as decrease and variance depends on the
distance between the subspaces you
wanted u2
so these are pretty much the choices
variance goes down estimator is biased
variance goes down and the decrease
depends
on the distance between the subspaces
same two for unbiased
okay um anyway so
if you like types these questions in the
chat i'll answer the first question
directly which is the estimator itself
is unbiased that's quite easy to see so
i possibly just quickly go through that
line
theta 2 is your signal projection of
theta null
theta null because the maximum
likelihood estimator for c terminal is
unbiased corresponds to the expected
value of theta null
then you can exchange the orthogonal
projection with the expectation operator
moves the projection inside and that
just simply gives you
the expected value of theta null
of theta2 and the estimator is unbiased
it's also straightforward to get the
covariance matrix
um c here corresponds to the covariance
matrix
of the maximum likelihood estimator for
c terminal
so the covariance matrix is changed
through these
orthogonal projections which you
multiply on the left and on the right
side
onto c mean squared error obviously
is an also straightforward unbiased v
nausea covariance no surprises here
in particular if i look at an element in
subspace u2 because your signal
projection applied
to an element in u2 just gives back the
element
so the mean squared error corresponds to
a transpose
c minus one a
so i wanted to in one slide to quickly
say something about optimal
experiment design which is kind of the
topic here
so my design points i will use finite
design points
so in a1 i have a little a1 to little a
d1
from which i can choose in a2 i have b1
to
be d2 so i will keep this notation
for the remaining slides i can sample
points ai mu i times
and sample bj lambda j times
so lambda used for b we are used for a
generally you have budget constraints
otherwise this whole upper terminal
experiment design
is quite boring so you will have upper
bounds
once the sum of the new eyes and upper
bounds on the lamp.js
i'm not allowing here any passing of bad
budget
so if you don't use budget in apple wand
you can't use it in epoch 2.
covariance matrix that corresponds to
the estimator
simply a weighted sum of the outer
products mu
i times the outer product a i lambda j
times the outer product b chain um
mean square error if i look at a point a
simply a transposed
times inverse or here i write
substituted inverse with a dagger
if c hilbert space is larger dimensional
and i don't have well-defined inverse
times a i will also use the notation so
this is the norm of a
under the c dagger covariance
um so just to mention one optimal design
simple optimal design is g optimal
design
where you try to minimize the worst case
mean squared error
in my particular setting say i'm in
epoch 2
minimizing the worst case error over a2
so i have this function g here defined
depending on my design points mu and
lambda
which corresponds to the worst element
in
my design points in a2 and the norm of
this first element
which i'm trying to minimize so i'm
trying to minimize this mu and lambda
says function g
picking my design points to minimize the
error in epoch2
simple example here two subspaces
blue and red two design points only very
simple
a corresponds to zero one one b two zero
one
question is here if i sample b one time
and i sample a mu times as mu increases
how does the error for b decrease
how will b change as mu goes off to
infinity
both are quite close to each other so i
guess the natural
prediction would be that the mean
squared error
will drop significantly as mu increases
so i have a small plot here which is
this one here
a is the uh sorry blue corresponds to
the mean square of a
which does what i at least expected
it goes down very fast as mu increases
here
on the x-axis i have the number of
samples i use for a
um the red curve or red line corresponds
to b
and the mean squared error of b which
now uses both samples and
does this projection onto the subspace
and what you can see here
was for me at least quite surprising so
zero improvement
in the estimator so you get a lot of
sample cna
arbitrary money really and the
estimation performance of b
does not improve at all um
i also have a small proposition um to
show that
i don't know if i have time for that but
i quickly just want to point out the
key ingredient and the setting partial
orders are actually quite useful
um so most of the results i'm stating
here just using some simple tricks with
partial orders
so what i'm having in mind here are
positive semi-definite matrices
which you can order as usual a smaller
than b
if the difference between them is psd
important is in this context that if you
reverse
sorry if you take inverses then you
reverse the order
a smaller b implies b minus 1 small a
minus 1.
and there's a version of that result for
substitute inverse which i need
if a is smaller than b then the range of
a which i don't know here this is r a
is a subset of the range of b and i have
this property here
that if i project onto the range of a
times b dagger
times the projection of the range of a
since this matrix
is smaller than a dagger if a was
smaller than b so the pseudo inverse in
some way also
reverses the order i actually was
interesting interested i
kind of derives this from scratch in two
pages but this must be
a complete standard result in some
engineering book i looked for a while
around to find
a reference for that so if anyone knows
a reference please let me know
so i double checked it i'm sure this is
correct but i just don't know the
good reference but
so these are quite useful simple results
which allow me to prove my first
proposition here
i'm comparing the estimator which uses
samples from
both apples that corresponds here to the
covariance matrix given here
so the one i've shown earlier weighted
linear combination of the outer products
of ai and bj
versus the estimator which totally
forgets about the samples in epoch 1
and uses this covariance matrix
and then what i can show is if my design
points are all linearly independent
some of that can be relaxed but i need
linear independence at least of the
elements a1
ad1 and b1 bd2
then the error bi
at city sign points so this is only for
the design points not for other points
the error at the design points using
samples from both epochs
is exactly the same error as
when i only use the samples from the
second apple so that's in some way
quite disappointing no improvement
whatsoever
at the design points from by using
samples from the first epoch
what this also is saying is that the
whole g optimal design doesn't make any
sense in this context
i can place in here potentially a best
weighting best sampling for my epoc 1
but it doesn't really matter the
function g the maximum norm over my
elements in the
second experiment is totally unaffected
by the design so the whole g optimal
design
doesn't really capture the multi-task
setting
i have a proof which i'll possibly skip
i don't know if we have later on a
chance that i could go through that it's
not too difficult
um but i think time was i'll just skips
as one
and let's move on just alert you you
have five minutes
so i have also another three slides so i
might go through another proof which i
have um
i think this would take a bit too long
but thanks
can i ask a quick question so have you
i think it's it's kind of like yeah you
want to have these eight vectors in the
intersection of the two subspaces and
like if you have that situation then
uh the e vectors can also have right
so that's the situation where i mean the
the subspaces have a non-trivial
intersection and then one test can have
the other
this is essentially what's happening
here
um i don't know
yeah it might be i think some intuition
like that i have said too yes yeah i
think so
um let's quickly go move on for the last
three four minutes take us a different
example sorry this figures
not particularly cute so let's
have a look consider now the subspace
corresponding to the span of b
and c i place one sample at c one sample
at b
um i have again my element a which i
will sample mu times
so potentially a lot of times and i'm
now interested in the mean squared error
at d
i don't have any points at d so d is not
a design point
but it lies in the span of c and b
so now at least you would hope that the
mean squared error at that point is
totally dominated by the point closest
to it
which is the point a and sets the points
at b and c which are very far from it
don't really have an impact so at least
now we would expect
or i would expect that the mean square
error decreases significantly with me
as we get more and more samples at it
so i've scribbled down the definitions
of these points but this is a secondary
so assume b and c as a single sample d
has no samples
and i'm interested in the mean squared
error of d
using also samples including a lot of
samples of a
this is a plot for it so the error for a
goes down as expected the error for d is
again
completely unaffected by the samples in
the first epoch
so even so b and c are miles away
from d they totally dominate the
estimate
of d completely ignoring any kind of
points
in a so i have another proposition which
kind of verifies this theoretically um
so same setting i might quickly discuss
this proof which is easy enough
um same settings so i have linearly
independent design points in the first
epoch corresponding to a1 to ad1 and
points b1
to bd2 corresponding to the design
points in airport2
all of them are linearly independent now
i take any element in the span
of the second design points so any
element in my subspace u2
and the mean squad error for b using all
the samples
is exactly the same as the mean squared
error for b using only the samples
from the secondary main idea of the
proof which
i have on some appendix slides is that
the design points
are orthogonal in the inner product
implied by c dagger and c tilde dagger
covariance so that is this line here
if i consider a i versus aj in this
induced inner product
since this is equal to zero if i
consider a i and b l
under this inner product since this is
equal to zero and same for
b l and b k so all these elements uh
if you like in the induced inner product
orthogonal
which then directly lets me translate my
earlier result to the setting
say b because it lies in the span of zpi
can be written as a linear combination
of these guys
and then i can just open up the two sums
so looking at this element here
substituting in the sums on both sides
moving the sums outside moving the ai's
outside
because of orthogonality the cross terms
cancel
i get here then a sum a single sum over
all the elements in the second epoch
with the weighting alpha i squared times
b i transposed c dagger bi
due to my earlier proposition which i
just stated
this is equal to b i transposed c tilde
dagger b
i and then i can decompose or recompose
these things back together
and i get b transposed c tilde dagger b
which corresponds to the mean squared
error so mean squared error
under c is exactly the same as means
quite error under c dagger
so all these samples are totally useless
when i'm using the maximum likelihood
estimator
okay so i just want to summarize quickly
so in this setting
unless the subspaces overlap in this
setting
the naive estimator or maximum
likelihood estimator is absolutely
useless
i don't gain any any benefits from
having multiple apples the samples are
totally used
wasted similarly the whole traditional
designs that you usually consider tree
optimal design a optimal design
and so on are not meaningful there's
nothing to design here
if i'm sticking to my knife estimator
which is the one which is underlying
classical
designs so then the question is are the
other natural estimators in the setting
which can benefit from samples of old
apples so you would hope so
and are there corresponding interesting
designs associated with these estimators
and i just want to stop here and say yes
to both
so we have some results on that but to
see these
we'll have to wait i guess for our
archive paper whenever this will come
out but there is hope so it's
not all lost the naive estimator is just
the wrong
choice for these settings okay thank you
thank you stefan uh while the third
speaker
uh shall i stop sharing when i set up
said so
yeah uh i just had a quick question so
i think you just pointed in the problem
and then there's like a teaser
you didn't get the solution but the idea
was
is the issue that the knife estimator is
not thinking about
other tasks like that's i guess the main
issue and
and it's just that the samples you would
collect
without thinking about other tasks are
just almost orthogonal
to the samples so yeah under this uh
inner product induced by the covariance
matrix they're completely orthogonal and
therefore um you don't profit from them
yes yes
[Music]
yeah yeah it's for me it was a bit
surprising um i thought in the beginning
for sure if points design points are
close by there must be profit but
yeah okay
yes maybe in the discussion session you
can give us a little bit of
overview of how one could handle it
i'm okay with that if you don't
mind revealing your secrets before you
archive it not that i have all the
secrets yet but i can remember
yeah sure all right
thanks uh all right we have our next
speaker